and dear fellow Scholars this is two
minute papers with Dr Carol Jonah ifahir
this is the amazing chat GPT a variant
of the gpt3 language model AI that was
Unleashed to read the internet and now
we can use it as a conversational agent
it has a lot of superpowers and today we
can even subject it to an IQ test in a
previous episode we saw that it could
write new song lyrics or even give us
ideas for designing a living room
however you see this is a language model
so it can only give us text not images
but no one said that we cannot plug in
these text prompts into a text to image
AI so these fellow Scholars did just
that and thus we could even see these
beautiful ideas come to life this was
one of my favorite examples and it turns
out we can even get chat GPT to give us
some beautiful imagery with some other
tricks and it can do even more here are
five more amazing examples that I
absolutely adore and would love to share
with you one we can ask it to create the
description of an SVG file which is a
vector image format this describes
in-text what kinds of objects go where
and are you thinking what I am thinking
oh yes this is an excellent way of using
text to create images so it can create
this red circle blue triangle or even a
face now if you think that is all it can
do then have a look at this for instance
can it create a vector version of the
Twitter logo
wow it can so cool okay okay but I am a
computer Graphics researcher by trade so
I would love to see something a little
more advanced so what other piece of
text is there that can create absolutely
beautiful images of course computer code
and hold on to your papers because here
it is two it can write proper pixel
shaders what is that this is a website
called Shader toy where we can submit a
piece of computer code that is executed
by our graphics cards and produces an
image oh yes an even more powerful way
of taking a piece of text and creating
beautiful images videos or even a
computer game with it and chat GPT can
even write these cool little programs
too they compile and run so well wow now
you you may be thinking are these just
some cute little test programs or are
they actually useful in any way well
three check this out this example shows
that it can even write computer code to
place a mirror in our computer game it
works like this yet another example of
using a tool for something that it was
not designed to do I absolutely love
these four when we are talking about
potential applications in the industry
here is another one
whoa Chad GPT can be asked to find and
even fix security holes in a piece of
computer code that is such an incredible
thing because it requires knowledge on
what happens if we execute a piece of
code and even better what potential
weaknesses may arise that feels like
talking to an intelligent being until we
ask it to multiply two numbers together
and it then feels spectacularly it is so
close but not quite correct one of the
amusing properties of a modern AI system
loving it five so actually how reliable
is it well it is not always that
unreliable a fellow scholar head GPT
take the SAT test and this dear fellow
Scholars is just about the SAT score for
an average human wow and it can also
take a linguistic IQ test and if you
have a closer look these questions
require a considerable English
vocabulary so what does this test think
check gpt's IQ is it says
147 holy matter of papers now before we
get too excited note that these are not
peer-reviewed experiments so I am
hesitant to give them too much Credence
and I hope you are too so please don't
take these too seriously however I feel
that these are likely early indications
of something amazing coming up real soon
I really hope that we will see a few
peer-reviewed papers on the academic
capabilities of chat GPT in more
rigorous tests soon so the original GPT
was an AI that was meant to read the
internet learn English and maybe be able
to finish incomplete Amazon reviews and
now it knows computer Graphics
programming cyber security has lots of
General human knowledge and more just
imagine what this will be able to do a
couple more papers down the line if you
have some ideas let me know in the
comments below and now if you have a Mac
computer you can even add it to your
menu bar to access it quickly and for
free how cool is that or plugins for all
major browsers now seem to be available
too so until the follow-up papers appear
let the experiments begin chat GPT has
inspired a lot of you fellow Scholars
all over the world and has reached a
million users in an incredibly small
amount of time that was one of the most
explosive transitions from a paper to a
real world product to show everyone that
the papers are real as real as it gets
weights and biases provides tools to
track your experiments in your deep
learning projects using their system you
can create beautiful reports like this
one to explain your findings to your
colleagues better it is used by many
prestigious Labs including openai Toyota
research GitHub and more and the best
part is that weights and biases is free
for all individuals academics and open
source projects make sure to visit them
through wnb.com papers or just click the
link in the video description and you
can get a free demo today our thanks to
weights and biases for their
long-standing support and for helping us
make better videos for you thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time